if you have
um
more lacks rules around casual sex
before marriage and uh birth control
which means that you can have sex
without fear of having children that
means that women can have sex with high
value men
who are outside of their typical dating
pool and perhaps higher value than they
would usually have access to which then
skews their
goals moving forward about who they want
to be in a long-term relationship with
what they don't understand is that that
man was prepared to give them sex but
not prepared to give them a relationship
relationship
yep
yes yes that's an incredibly important
point here uh
it's
it's a matter of knowing what's
available and what you can actually
attain being realistic about your
romantic prospects so that high value
man that is a top 10 percent earner that
drives a bugatti was probably never
going to entertain a romantic
relationship with you so
why try to court him
at the outset right what was the benefit
there maybe it was it was a fun night
and maybe you do enjoy
engaging with them but you are right
when you say that it probably distorts
their perception of what then is
available because if if you do have this
experience with this guy and it was a
fantastic experience and your head over
heels for him
you want to replicate that experience in
in in the next-door relationships you
have but if that guy that you're dating
doesn't quite reach that standard you're
never going to be happy well which girl
wants to admit to herself that this guy
with the nice car and the good abs only
wants me to [ __ ] me no one wants no no
girl's going to be able to
do that you know you not only would you
probably not know but even if you did
know you wouldn't be able to justify it
to yourself in any case um
you know it's the same as the guy the
same as the guy that sleeps with the
really really ugly girl he'll probably
justify it to himself as well actually
she's not that bad and it's just that
the only thing no dude it's because
you've had eight pints and you're in a
city that you've never been in before
and you're lonely that's why yes yes yes
uh somebody's delay right yes correct
i don't know man i think um i think it'd
be very difficult for a girl to kind of
concede that point
you know
one of the main reasons would be
men give off signals of long-term mating
strategies very few men you know no
matter how alpha you are are going to
say hope that you've got your uber
booked for 3 30 a.m tonight um type
thing as you're on the as you're on the
way back oh hi mate can you just wait
outside in the cab while while we get
this done and then you can take her home
most men aren't honest and open about
their short-term mating intentions which
let's lead leading women on yes
i think that that is true but at the
same time
does
does being open make a man more or less
attractive with regard to his intention
so if if you met a girl right away and
you took her out on a first date or even
maybe even a second date and you said to
her
my intention is to marry you does that
make you more or less attractive if you
are that transparent i mean what do you
think maybe
i would say that's probably coming on
too strong that's crummy on too strong
right so that sort of transparency may
not necessarily work in that particular
situation
well the most bizarre thing is that
the men who have
no intention of being in a long-term
relationship with you usually give off
signals that they do
and the men who do want to be in a
long-term relationship with you try to
give off signals that they're not
yes but but that's the thing though is
that it's it's a strange it's a strange
way that um
i suppose the female mind perceives
attractive males and it probably comes
back to the point about attention is
that you want that which you cannot have
you know and if you can't have the the
man that is uh you know the upper
echelon of man the high value man you'll
want him even more
roll the clock forward for me then like
there's gonna be a lot of single women
in future what's gonna happen there
because um do you think that women can
uh reset their hypergamous nature
no no that's that's an evolutionary
fixture that's gonna stick around for
quite a while uh things are probably
gonna get far worse than they are better
before everything is said and done
what's that mean but um well
it means i think we're probably going to
see a lot more
violence with with relation to in cells
i think that's probably going to go up
as a result of the influx of lonely
single men
and
of course you're going to see quite a
bit more depression among single single
women in fact i think there's a
statistic out there that indicates that
women
caucasian females between the ages of 40
and 45 have the highest rates of
antidepressant use
and that is probably going to increase
as as time goes on but probably spread
out to other age demographics 40 and 45
i believe so so do you think that that's
women who have perhaps
uh not dated or dated unsuccessfully and
made it to the wall uh without a partner
and are now
accepting their sort of
childless future
yes i i think so but there is there is
some saving grace so if i were to added
a
contradictory statistic here it's that
the only
uh demographic among females where
there's been an increase in in
infertility and in children being born
is that same demographic is women
between the ages of 40 and 40 45. i want
to say i want to say that more women had
in 2019 had children over the age of 40
than under the age of 20. correct
correct that's exactly correct i think
um so peer research actually put out a
study not too long ago and it 20
uh 2016 was 80 of women uh between the
age of 40 and 45 that had a a child and
that actually increased by six percent
as of 2019.
that's correct it's slowly it's yeah
it's slowly ticking upwards what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace